this morning we're going to begin with a
look into the allegations into the inner
workings of the Church of Scientology
they come in a new book it's called a
billion years Mike rinder details the
the decades he spent as a high-ranking
Scientology member the book is published
by an imprint of Simon and Schuster
that's a division of our parent company
Paramount Global in a wide-ranging
interview rinder told Chief
investigative correspondent Jim Axelrod
about his experience as a high up
official in the organization Jim also
spoke to a Scientology representative
who disputes many of rinder's claims and
calls him an unreliable source and a
quote inveterate liar Jim good morning
good morning founded in the early 1950s
with a remarkable origin story involving
Galactic Warlords rocket ships and 75
million year old volcanoes Scientology
State church leaders is a belief system
designed to Foster spiritual
enlightenment Mike rinder grew up in the
church but he told me he went from
wanting to save the world with
Scientology to wanting to save the world
from Scientology
Mike how you doing Mike rinder is no fan
of Scientology please welcome Mr Mike
rinder
which is remarkable since he spent 46
years of his life in the church rising
to a high-ranking position I told a lot
of lies when I was the spokesperson for
Scientology his Memoir a billion years
describes an organization built on the
teachings of one man scientology's
founder L Ron Hubbard We Believe The
elrond Habit had the answers to
everything about life and L Ron Hubbard
based his General view of how to fix all
problems facing mankind what did he
ground it in
but
Hubbard who'd been a science fiction
writer recorded 3 000 lectures on how to
handle every conceivable challenge a
Scientologist could face which he
blended with some outrageous claims El
Ron Hubbard says for instance smoking
doesn't cause cancer yeah not smoking
enough causes cancer right but that's
sort of insanity
is also indicative of just how powerful
the grip on people's minds is
scientology's journey to spiritual
enlightenment is done through a series
of courses that rinder says costs money
a lot of money three hundred five
hundred thousand that's for you to pay
for your own participation in
Scientology this is why I said it's a
business masquerading as a religion does
it cost 300 400 500 000 to reach
spiritual enlightenment no absolutely
not for more than three decades Monique
Yingling who emphasized that she's a
practicing Catholic has been a lawyer
for the church the total contributions
that you would be asked for if you did
every single course on the training
route would be less than fifty thousand
dollars closer to 20 or 30 or something
like that I can assure you we are not
what you expect in 1987 David miscavige
took over as leader of the church
following Hubbard's death rinder left
the church 20 years later after he says
he he was punished by Miss cabbage
following a news account critical of
Scientology rinder says Miss cabbage
sent him to the hole a Detention Center
on the grounds of scientology's
headquarters in Southern California it
consisted of two double wide trailers
that have been put on foundations and
connected and it was how many people
might be in the hall at one time well I
counted at one point that there was a
hundred and thirty 130 and two double
wides yes
and the doors were bad there was
bathrooms but no showers uh the sleeping
Arrangements were on the floor there's
no such thing as the whole it's it is a
startling
if not stunning description
why would he lie about this because it's
salacious and what draws the media's
attention is throwing in all these
salacious details that are always
categorically untrue
not always categorically untrue I'm not
saying that and I you know and I think
there's always a grain of Truth to
everything myself so as someone who's
been around the church for 35 years
what's the granted truth here the grain
of Truth is that there the church does
have a system of internal discipline
when
um that individuals and for the most
part individuals volunteer for it and
they say they're just very grateful that
they had the opportunity first of all to
redeem themselves and to study more
fully the scriptures of Scientology
rinder says leaving the church was one
thing but untangling himself from a
lifetime following scientology's belief
system was much more difficult you leave
in 2007 but you still hold on to the
teachings when did you finally reach a
point where like oh my goodness what was
I in the grips of it took about six
years six years to what to come to that
conclusion that no this is a load of
crap it's very difficult
to accept the fact that you have been so
stupid I don't think that you can take
Mike render at his word when he's
answered your questions in the interview
one thing Mike rinder and Monique
Yingling do agree on the Church of
scientology's vast wealth when I left in
2007 I knew that between the two major
arms of Scientology that accumulated
about two billion dollars in money and
assets that has increased a lot since
then what's the church worth
foreign
I can't give you a dollar figure but as
I said a bit earlier the church does
have a very generous parishioners well
hang on you can't give me a dollar
figure but you're one of the lead
attorneys in dealing with all the tax
issues you must have a sense of the net
worth of the Church of Scientology
well the church does have
hundreds of millions billions well the
real question is what are what does the
church use its assets for and it uses
its assets to afford its religious and
charitable Mission am I accurate in
describing the assets of the church in
billions probably yes all of that money
raised from its millions of members real
estate in Prime locations is tax-free as
the IRS granted Scientology the same tax
exempt status as other major religions
in 1993 people are watching Mike rinder
what do you want people to know who are
watching him
share his view of what he says his
experience was I think your your
listeners need to know that he is paid
for attacking the church that this is
Money Motivated Mike renders only source
of income
for the last 15 years or so has been
based on his being a Critic of the
church rinder denies those claims
telling CBS News my criticism of
Scientology is driven solely by my
desire to end the rampant ongoing abuses
within the organization it is
Scientology that is obsessed with making
money you know people are going to watch
this and be like hang on a second this
guy was the spokesman for the Church of
Scientology you admitted to me in the
interviews you told a lot of lies so why
are we supposed to believe what you're
telling us about scientology now I can't
convince you one way or the other
whether I am lying now or then or both
you just got to sort of
look at me and go is there a reason for
him to lie now there is no reason for me
to lie now the only thing that I am
trying to accomplish is stop people from
getting
abused by Scientology
today rinder lives in Florida not so far
from Scientology spiritual headquarters
in Clearwater when rinder left
Scientology he left behind a wife and
two children wow this book he says is
dedicated to his kids who he hopes will
one day leave the organization in
response to the book rinder's children
wrote an open letter to rinder calling
the Memoir self-serving they wrote quote
you were not our father stop telling
lies about us your family our friends
and our beliefs
hmm whoa doesn't sound a lot to um yeah
reconciliation imminent by any means had
to be very painful though to hear those
words coming from your own children it
was and he says look all I can do is
make the invitation he makes it clear in
the in the book that he is hoping to
leave the door open but clearly from the
response that door is going to remain
closed for quite a while so what's he
doing now so he lives actually not too
far from the church headquarters he has
a another wife and a new family she too
is a former Scientologist wow really
powerful interview Jim yeah thank you
thanks well done thank you sir